قال المستشار الالماني سنه من بين القاده
القلائل الذين يحافظون على التواصل مع
الرئيس روسيا
ودفع في حوار له مع مواطني في مدينه مارك
غربي المانيا ان ابقاء خطوط التواصل مع
الرئيس الروسي تهدف للبحث عن مخرج من
الفوضى
كنت من القلائل الذين يحافظون على خط
التواصل مع بوتين كنت في موسكو وتحدثت معه
هناك لمده اربع ساعات تحدثت معه عبر
الهاتف مرارا وتكرارا منذ ذلك الحين وعازم
على الاستمرار في ذلك من المهم ابقاء خط
التواصل معه من اجل البحث عن مخرج لهذه
الفوضى على روسيا ان تدرك انها لن تفلح في
الاستيلاء بالقوه على اجزاء من اراضي
اوكرانيا وعليها سحب قواتها حتى يمكن
تحقيق سلام عادل بين البلدين
وحذر من خطوره تصعيد في حرب روسيا التي
وصفها بالمعتدي على اوكرانيا واضاف ان
التصعيد يعني ان الحرب ستصبح مباشره بين
روسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي وافقه
اذا حدث تصعيد في الحرب فلن تبقى حربا بين
روسيا المعتديه واوكرانيا التي ندعمها بل
ستصبح حربا بين روسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي
لهذا السبب لدينا مسؤوليه نتحملها للقيام
بكل شيء لضمان عدم حدوث هذا التصعيد عندما
قال البعض في بدايه الحرب انه يتعين علينا
انشاء منطقه حظر طيران هذا امر غير ممكن
هذا سيؤدي الى تصعيد فوري للحرب وستتقاتل
فيه طائرات النيتو والطائره الروسيه لن
نفعل هذا وهذا نفس موقف الرئيس الامريكي
عندما بدا النقاش فجاه عن الطائرات
المقاتله فانا اخبرك اننا سنواصل المسار
والابقاء على الامور متوازنه بالتنسيق مع
الاخرين ونتجنب اي تصعيد يؤدي الى حرب بين
روسيا والنيتو